so pelosi is creating a reputation of
being a sidekick
and she's being called a sidekick by
young people on tickets i still prefer
yours if we can go to that article
for uh pelosi if you have it up uh here
we go pelosi adds provision to no this
is not a buddy this is not a buddy i
just texted you
oh my gosh here we go again you just got
the email and
this guy
don't pull that and see look
danielle while we're waiting break this
down debt per citizen eighty six
thousand
eight eighty six thousand dollars debt
per citizen two hundred and twenty
including eight thousand mortgage debt
per taxpayer jesus
that's why we need somebody young and
dynamic to try and take this
tackle this
okay so people are calling that uh
pelosi a sidekick especially young
investors and this is why
tick-tockers are trading stocks by
copying what members of congress do okay
uh whale alert nancy pelosi just bought
11 million dollars in four stocks
the women of investing just spent three
hundred thousand dollars on this stock
how to join the exclusive group chat so
at the end they're giving a shout out to
what pelosi is doing young investors
have a new strategy watching financial
disclosure sitting members of congress
for stock tips among a certain community
of individual investors on tick tock
house speaker nancy pelosi stock trading
disclosures are a treasure trove shout
out to nancy pelosi the stock market's
biggest whale says user ceo watch list
another said i've come to conclusion
that nancy pelosi is a sidekick while
adding that she is the queen of
investing she knew declared chris
josephs analyzing a particular trade on
policies and financial disclosures and
you would have known if you had followed
her portfolio last year joseph's noticed
that the trades actually made by
pelosi's investor husband and merely
disclosed by the speaker were performing
well joseph is a co-founder of a company
called iris which shows other people's
stock trades in the past year and a half
whoops he has been taking advantage of a
law called the stock act which requires
lawmakers to disclose stock trading and
those of their spouses within 45 days
now on joseph social investing platforms
you can use a push notification every
time pelosi stop trading disclosures are
released he's personally investing when
he sees which stocks are picked i'm at
the point where if you can you can't
beat them join them joseph told npr
adding that if he sees traits on her
disclosures i typically do buy the next
one she does i'm going to buy okay a
policy spokesperson said that she does
not personally own any stock and the
transactions are made by her husband she
has to do that protection the speaker
has no prior knowledge of subsequent
involvement any transactions at the
spokesperson so joseph's view trades by
federal lawmakers as smart money would
work following and plans to take large
variety of politicians we don't want
this to be a left or right thing we
really don't care we just want to make
money okay there you have it can you do
me a
kind of a vegas website
it gives you predict i t i t
who will yup yup top one
i love this
oh his price is up to 75 cents today his
price was at 66
he was at 66 percent yesterday do you
want to know why why because they
forced rob kaplan who was the president
of the of the dallas fed and they forced
eric rosengren who was the president of
the boston fed to step down because they
found out about the insider trading but
they didn't force them to disgorge
they
well do you think that's coming with
hearings they announced they announced
that they were going to be selling stock
very soon and getting rid of the
positions that made it even worse but
all i'm saying is so you're saying
september
on september 12th jerome powell's
chances of being the next fed chair were
92 percent the reason they've declined
is that there is a fear that because of
this insider trading scandal at the
federal reserve that he's not going to
be confirmed
this shines a bright light on the fact
that the sec and somebody needs to
change the law to make it if if it's not
okay for federal reserve officials to
to basically insider trade why is it
okay for nancy pelosi to be the queen of
insider trading there's a law against
that it's called the
securities and exchange commission the
sec insider trading is against the law
why should congress have a different set
of rules
well they're special people daniel i
mean why are you complaining about that
these people are okay to make that kind
of money because we want our politicians
to be rich and if this is one day one
way they do it what's wrong with that
right
do you speak sarcasm don't you yeah i do
i do i just looked at all those five
people all those five names go back at
it go back at the five names you know
the next five names that they're talking
about they're all democrats
any reason why
elizabeth warren wants leo brainerd to
be the next fed chair because lail
brainard will facilitate modern monetary
theory universal basic income
she will paint the glide path i just
looked her up for your worst nightmare
negative interest rates and giving money
directly to the united states people
through accounts at the federal reserve
putting the conventional banking system
in the united states of america out of
business that's why elizabeth warren is
pounding the table on lil lail brainerd
and saying if the the head of the dallas
fed and the head of the boston fed were
forced to resign damn it jerome powell
should be as well that's why elizabeth
warren is saying it because she wants
lail brainerd to put socialism in the
law in america
warren praises brainerd slams powell
this is just recently she called a few
days ago she said that powell was a
dangerous man a dangerous man does he
look dangerous to you dangerous he looks
wealthy
he is wealthy but he was wealthy before
he was worth a hundred million dollars
before he started at the fed he served
he only did this to serve his country
not because he needed a pension
afterwards
but lael brainerd that's a different
story yeah you see the walt's elizabeth
warren says she will vote against second
term for fed's jerome powell
uh
mr warren
congressional so so she's not fond of
this guy and she's willing to vote
against him so rapunzel comes
by the way while you're at it you almost
pulled up something that was brilliant
kai pull up lael brainerd husband just
do it
just do it
i mean you want to talk about a dc power
couple
ever heard of kirk campbell
one of biden's biggest chinese advisors
that's mr brainerd
thank you that's her husband that guy's
chinese no
he has been
he's one of biden's advisors on china
danielle what group
administration what grade would you give
this is nasty dc politicking what grade
would you give jerome powell for his
tenure as chairman of the fed
probably a
c minus or a d okay
and uh when janet yellen was there
that's about where i was at he's doing
okay janet yellen an f she's out who's
the last person you'd give a decent
grade to paul volcker
when was he
he was right before alan greenspan came
in and started
basically
that was the night backstopping
investors 90s 80s he's the one who
tackled inflation so you're saying we
haven't we haven't had a passing grade
decent no chairperson of the fed but i'm
not i mean but before you you could stop
anybody in my world and they would say
the exact same thing who was the last
good fed
greenspan bernanke none of these guys it
is unanimous and and everybody will tell
you paul volcker who was the who was the
best recent fed chair i don't think
there has been one
you you
so you didn't like paul volcker
well vocal oh big doc just dropped the
hammer on danielle right there
you're right
i'm sorry because i said
he didn't give a [ __ ] about wall street
and he broke the back of inflation and
he had the balls to do it and he stood
up to
he stood up to his own board there was
mutiny mutiny on his federal reserve
board where they tried to oust him and
he broke the back of inflation when the
country needed it he had the balls to do
it
what's your rebuttal biz doc let her
know no i think she i think she's
correct on that but you know our federal
reserve board
i've got deeper thoughts about it that
align the line with her
corrupt institution so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]